♪♪
-If you don't mind,
I'm gonna get to the news.
President Biden on Thursday
delivered
a rare prime time address
from Philadelphia's
Independence Hall,
and not,
as I originally thought,
the Upside Down.
[ Laughter ]
That is a wild lighting choice.
I...kept expecting him
to be interrupted by Vecna.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden traveled
to Pittsburgh yesterday,
which was his third trip
to Pennsylvania
in less than a week.
Not to be outdone,
Dr. Oz also made
his third trip to Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
Election day is nine weeks away,
and only time will tell
if Republicans gain seats
or if it was rigged.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
and First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
are set to host the Obamas
on Wednesday at the White House
for the unveiling of
their official portraits,
and you can tell
Biden misses the old days,
because this is
his official portrait.
[ Laughter ]
Maine Senator Susan Collins
said in a new interview
that she believes that Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
will get a vote on same-sex
marriage protections this month
but added that she hopes
he will "resist the urge to play
politics with the bill."
It's the Senate.
It's all politics.
That's like saying
you hope the Jets resist
the urge to play football.
Okay, Jets...
[ Laughter ]
Jets is a bad example, but...
...you get the point.
During his speech in Wisconsin
yesterday, President Biden
said that not every Republican
is "a MAGA Republican,"
which is a little like saying
that not every zombie
eats brains.
Maybe, but they also don't mind
if the other zombies
eat your brain.
[ Laughter ]
Two Air France pilots
were suspended recently
after a physical fight
in the cockpit during a flight.
The fight
was reportedly so intense
that one of them
dropped his cigarette.
[ Laughter ]
New -- [ Chuckles ]
New footage of the Titanic
wreckage was recently released
in the highest screen resolution
currently available.
They zoomed in as far
as they could,
and bad news, you guys --
no survivors.
[ Laughter ]
[ Woman "aws" ]
Well, we know now.
It's high resolution,
so we know now.
You know what would be worse?
A survivor.
[ Laughter ]
"Aw."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
A large spill of Alfredo sauce
recently shut down an interstate
highway in Tennessee.
Well, it wouldn't be
the first time
Alfredo sauce
clogged a major artery.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we're -- You know,
when we read a story like that
we're worried, obviously,
that our monologue writers
caused the accident.
[ Laughter ]
According to New York State Park
officials,
hundreds of people at Long
Island beaches over the weekend
were stung by jellyfish.
At least, I assume that's why
they were all peeing
on each other.
[ Laughter ]
That's my assumption.
And finally, rapper Eminem won
an Emmy Award over the weekend
and now just needs a Tony Award
to achieve
so-called EGOT status,
so look for him this fall
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
[ Laughter ]
FBI agents reportedly found
a document while searching
former President Trump's
Mar-A-Lago residence
that detailed a foreign
country's nuclear capabilities.
Even crazier, it was Luxembourg.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Obama returned
today to the White House.
Oh, God, it must have been
like one of those videos
where a dog's owner
returns from the war.
[ As Obama ] "Joe, Joe!
I'm happy to see you, too.
All right, get down, Joe,
get down."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Former Trump
strategist Steve Bannon
is reportedly expected
to turn himself in
to New York state
prosecutors tomorrow
to face a criminal indictment,
and if he's convicted,
he could actually find himself,
for the first time,
sleeping indoors.
[ Laughter ]
During a White House
coronavirus briefing yesterday,
Dr. Anthony Fauci
said the COVID vaccines
will likely become annual,
like flu shots or,
you know, mask-wearing.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Hillary Clinton said
that she started wearing
pantsuits in the '90s
while she was First Lady
after a Brazilian ad agency
used a photo of her wearing
a skirt in a lingerie campaign.
And I don't think I need to tell
you who was the first to notice.
"Hey, Hillary,
you're in a magazine!"
[ Laughter ]
It was reported yesterday that
Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz once said
in an interview that incest is
"not a big problem if you're
more than a first cousin away."
Replied the interviewer, "My
question was about tax policy."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
16% of Americans said
that they share
and track locations
with their friends and family.
Though, honestly, a lot of them
do now regret that.
[ Laughter ]
"Should we check on
where Uncle Tom is?"
Ay-yi-yi-yi-yi-yi-yi!
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin
returned from the Senate's
August recess yesterday
with his right sling --
right arm in a sling.
But that's also his right sling.
[ Light laughter ]
West Virginia Senat-- Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's coming off the rails.
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin returned
from the Senate's
August recess yesterday
with his right arm in a sling.
Well, now we know how Biden
got his climate bill passed.
[ Laughter ]
Um, yeah, I think we ordered
this with a neck!
[ Laughter ]
You know, the Biden picture.
Rapper Snoop Dogg has announced
that he's releasing
a new breakfast cereal...
[ Laughter ]
...called Snoop Loopz.
And if you thought your kids
fought over the prize before...
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurring ]
"No, it didn't have a prize."
[ Laughter ]
New York's education chancellor,
David Banks, confirmed yesterday
that public school students will
not get snow days this year.
When asked why, he said, "'Cause
it's 91 degrees in September."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Target recently issued a recall
for white fudge animal cookies,
because they potentially contain
metal wire.
Even worse, apparently,
they also contain white fudge.
[ Laughter ]
At the White House ceremony
for the unveiling
of former President Obama
and First Lady Michelle Obama's
official portraits,
President Biden said
Obama was one of the,
"most consequential presidents
in our history."
"That is true,"
said the consequence.
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Kathy Hochul
announced yesterday
that masks will be optional
on public transportation.
This comes almost 18 months
after passengers made
the same announcement.
[ Laughter ]
"What?
Starting today? Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Former Trump strategist
Steve Bannon turned himself in
to New York authorities today
to face state criminal charges.
Well, the good news is,
I'm positive
this man knows how
to make toilet wine.
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced
that President Biden will travel
to Boston on Monday
to speak about his initiative
to end cancer.
'Cause if there's one thing
we've learned from Boston --
anything is possible.
[ Laughter ]
He got her back!
Democratic Senate candidate
John Fetterman agreed yesterday
to debate Republican
Dr. Mehmet Oz.
Apparently he's trying
to get under Oz's skin
by making him drive back
to Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
"Ah, put it in Google Maps!"
That's right.
Democratic Senate candidate
John Fetterman agreed yesterday
to debate Republican
Dr. Mehmet Oz.
We're not sure when,
so here's a clip from
"Punch-Out" to tide you over.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-According to
the latest numbers,
the average American
life expectancy has fallen
to 76.1 years old.
But don't tell that
to the 2024 election.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
"Hey, we're both above average."
[ As Trump ]
"We are, it's true.
We're both a little bit
better than average."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
According to new research,
ocean water
in the Northern Hemisphere
has been unusually warm.
"Sorry," said this kid.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
I didn't know
what the face would be,
but that's what
it's supposed to be.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book, former
President Trump once tried
to pay for an attorney's
legal fees with a horse.
Not Rudy, though.
When it was time to pay Rudy,
Trump said,
"Does anyone have change
for a pigeon?"
[ Laughter ]
So, he wanted to pay him
with less than a pigeon.
He wanted change -- he didn't
want to pay Rudy a full pigeon.
He needed change for a pigeon
to then give slightly less
than one pigeon's worth.
[ As Giuliani ] "No one said
I did a full pigeon's worth!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Normal voice ] And finally,
officials in Nigeria
recently seized 16 sacks filled
with thousands of donkey penises
that were set to be illegally
exported to Hong Kong.
The mistake?
Bringing them as a carry-on.
[ Laughter ]
You know what the great thing
about that joke is?
It doesn't answer
any of the questions I have
about the news story.
We just all assumed
the audience would be like,
"Uh-huh, cool,
16,000 donkey penises.
Of course you'd want those."
[ Laughter ]
"I have no follow-ups.
Just get to the joke, please."
That was the monologue,
everybody!
♪♪